President Trump appears to be having a
banner day after one of our closest
allies laid out evidence basically
backing up what the president's been
saying all along about the Iran nuclear
deal this is another world leader said
that President Trump should get the
Nobel Peace Prize for a breakthrough in
relations with North Korea chief White
House correspondent John Roberts joins
us from the North Lawn with all the
developments today good evening John
bracket evening to you for months if not
a couple of years now President Trump
has insisted that Iran is not in
compliance with the jcpoa the joint
comprehensive plan of action otherwise
known as the Iran nuclear deal that's
one reason why late last year despite
loud criticism he decertified it and
also despite the fact that the UN and as
we saw James Madison fied that Iran is
in compliance speaking in the Rose
Garden with the president of Nigeria
President Trump said of the evidence
revealed by Israel today I told you so
that is just not an acceptable situation
and I've been saying that's happening
they're not sitting back idly they're
setting off missiles which they say are
for television purposes I don't think so
president Trump faces at may 12th
deadline to either sign another waiver
of sanctions against Iran or pull out of
the nuclear deal I'm not telling you
what I'm doing but a lot of people think
they know and order before the 12th will
make a decision in his meetings with
president McCrone last week President
Trump indicated he may be open to
leaving the Iran nuclear deal in place
if the US and its allies can get a new
separate deal to address Aaron's
long-term nuclear program ballistic
missiles and destabilizing behavior that
doesn't mean I wouldn't negotiate a new
agreement we'll see what happens but I
think of anything what's happening today
and what's happened over the last little
while and what we've learned has really
shown that I've been 100% right on North
Korea President Trump today called an
audible tweeting that his pending summit
with Kim jong-un should take place at
the DMZ in the same location Kim in
South Korean president moon jae-in met
last week well it was an interesting
thought and I think that some people
maybe don't like the look of that and
some people like it very much
I threw it out today as an idea
president Trump's advisors had
repeatedly ruled out a summit on the
Korean Peninsula but Fox News is told
that President Trump loved the image of
Kim jong-un walking across the border to
shake hands with the South Korean
president and thinks to have him there
to greet Kim would be a much more
powerful statement than meeting in some
third country there's something that I
like about it because you're there
you're actually there where if things
work out there's a great celebration to
be had on the site not in a third party
country and more confidence-building
steps between South and North Korea the
North today announcing it will sync its
time zone with South Korea on May 5th
beyond yang had been 30 minutes earlier
a small gesture but one to which South
Korean officials attach a great deal of
significance
telekinesis I think this measure is
being taken to show that such measures
carry out his will and will be taking
place at a fast pace in turn South Korea
will tomorrow begin dismantling the
loudspeaker system that for decades has
been blasting propaganda and kpop music
across the DMZ into North Korea over the
weekend the South Korean president moon
jae-in credited president Trump with
bringing Kim jong-un to the table today
he told people he believes President
Trump deserves to be recognized with the
Nobel Peace Prize friend